.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ganz ehrlich, es ist schon mühsam -
mit den Wunden, die man kleben muss,
dann geht es nicht,
man muss Kleider wechseln,
duschen usw.
Der Scheiss
ist schon eine Behinderung.
Immer Theater.
Ja, aber eben ...
Ich kann den Vergleich nicht machen.
Ich hätte fast gesagt:
"Andere haben Kinder."
Mit Kindern muss man auch immer
waschen, putzen und rennen.
Das ist auch ein Aufwand.
Die können das ja auch.
Ich bin wie mein eigenes Kleinkind,
das ich behandeln und pflegen muss.
Ein Kind macht am Ende des Tages
aber glücklicher
als eine chronische Krankheit,
das muss man auch noch sagen.
Die chronische Krankheit
heisst Colitis ulcerosa.
Das Sorgenkind von Robin Rehmann
ist sein Darm.
Robin Rehmann -
das ist der Mann bei SRF Virus,
der psychisch
und chronisch kranken Menschen
mit seiner Radiosendung
"Sick of Silence" eine Stimme gibt.
Und nicht so tun,
als wäre alles gut.
Er selber leidet seit sieben Jahren
an einer Autoimmunerkrankung.
Sein ganzes Leben dreht sich um sei-
nen chronisch entzündeten Dickdarm.
Doch das soll sich ändern.
Im Juli 2018 fällt er die bisher
wichtigste Entscheidung seines Lebens
und hält diese in einem Video fest.
Ich mache am 24. August
eine totale Kolektomie.
D.h.,
man nimmt den ganzen Dickdarm raus.
Einfach wird es nicht.
Es sind drei Operationen,
schwere Eingriffe.
Das wird mich sicher mindestens
ein Jahr lang beschäftigen.
Das ist dann für immer.
Der Dickdarm
kommt nicht mehr zurück.
Es ist egal,
wie sich die Medizin entwickelt.
Ich will wieder der sein,
der ich bin.
Jemand, der nicht so kaputt ist,
der wieder Spass am Leben hat.
Und nicht immer wieder
so erschöpft ist, Bauchweh hat ...
Es ist einfach ein Scheiss.
Wünscht mir Glück.
Die Entfernung des Dickdarms
soll wieder Normalität
in sein Leben bringen.
Ja, ja, kommt schon gut.
Hoffentlich.
Von nun an begleite ich meinen
Arbeitskollegen Robin mit der Kamera.
Zwei Jahre lang.
Von Risiken und Lebensqualität,
von Schmerz und Glück -
davon handelt dieser Film.
Das Video, in dem er seinen Entscheid
bekannt gibt, sehen Tausende.
Mit seinem Colitis-ulcerosa-Vlog
lässt er die Welt an seinem Leben
und seiner Krankheitsgeschichte
teilhaben.
Darauf kriegte ich
sehr viele Kommentare -
von Freunden und von anderen.
Das sind wahrscheinlich über 100.
Es geht nicht darum,
mich in Szene zu setzen,
sondern darum, chronisch kranken
Menschen ein Gesicht zu geben.
Es gibt viele von ihnen
in der Schweiz.
Zu zeigen, in was für einer Situa-
tion man ist, wie man sich fühlt.
Die Gefühle gegen aussen zu zeigen.
Das wird auf Social Media
normalerweise gegenteilig gemacht.
Man zeigt die Muskeln und Stärken
und alles ist gut.
Meine Art von Social-Media-Beiträgen
ist eher das Gegenteil:
Ich zeige Schwäche und ...
... meine innere Zerrissenheit
und meinen Kampf.
Ich glaube, dass sich damit viel
mehr Leute identifizieren können,
weil das jeder selber kennt.
Tatsächlich leiden in der Schweiz
mehr als 2 Mio. Menschen
an einer lang andauernden Krankheit,
die nicht vollständig
geheilt werden kann.
Bei Robin fing alles 2012 an.
Der Fernseh- und Radiomoderator
war Anfang 30.
Ein Workaholic.
Einer, der den Exzess liebte
und für jeden Unsinn zu haben war.
Nach einem Konzert
mit seiner Punkband
hatte er erstmals
diese schrecklichen Bauchkrämpfe.
Ich habe bad news:
Mein Bauch
spinnt wieder mal auf alle Seiten.
Wenn ich aufs WC gehe,
sieht es auch nicht schön aus.
Und das seit drei Wochen.
Wenn du dem Videoblog zuschaust,
weisst du,
dass ich seit drei Wochen
schwierigen Stuhlgang habe.
Schön, hier darüber zu reden.
Und jetzt gerade
ist es wieder schlimm.
Anders
als bei einer Magen-Darm-Grippe
hörten Durchfall und Krämpfe
nie mehr auf.
Darmblutungen kamen hinzu.
Bis zu 30 Stuhlgänge am Tag -
auch unkontrollierte. Ein Albtraum.
... mein iPad, um Filme zu gucken.
Sein unbeschwertes Leben
als Partymacher und Entertainer
war plötzlich vorbei.
Robin zog sich immer mehr zurück,
war häufig allein
und verbrachte die Tage
auf dem Sofa und der Toilette.
Es drehte sich alles
um die Krankheit,
um mögliche Ursachen,
um die Symptombekämpfung,
um Medikamente
und alternative Heilmethoden.
Ich meine, was ich
schon alles probiert habe ...
Ich habe früher alles gemacht:
von Hypnose,
über Drachenblut trinken ...
Das ist
so eine komische, rote Frucht.
Die hat mir jemand geschickt.
Oder nur noch Karottensuppe essen.
Entspannungstherapien
mache ich natürlich auch:
Cranio-Sacral, Meditation und so.
All diese Dinge sind nicht falsch,
da ist schon was dran.
Aber es heilt die schwere chronische
und unheilbare Krankheit nicht.
Das war dann plötzlich
an einem Morgen.
Ich stand im Bad vor dem Spiegel.
Es war wie ein Geistesblitz:
"Du musst den Dickdarm rausnehmen."
Das war für mich ganz klar.
Dann habe ich alles
in die Wege geleitet.
Mittlerweile habe ich auch
wieder Anfälle, bei denen ich denke,
dass ich den Dickdarm
besser nicht rausnehme.
Kacken ist schon schön,
wenn es richtig geht.
Wenn man weiss,
dass es nie mehr geht ...
Komisch. Da sagt wohl niemand:
"Klar, mache ich."
Weil er unsicher ist, redet er in der
Zeit vor der Operation mit Leuten,
die bereits eine Dickdarmentfernung
hinter sich haben.
Wenn man jemanden hat wie Dominik,
der sagt,
er merke, wie es besser geht
und dass es positiv sei ...
Das gibt mir etwas Sicherheit.
Logisch treffe ich auch Leute,
die das Gegenteil sagen.
Ich habe leider Kontakt zu jemandem,
der sagt,
das war der dümmste Entscheid ever.
Krass.
Das macht dann
natürlich schon etwas Angst.
Es sind 20 % oder etwas weniger,
die sagen,
es ginge ihnen nach der Operation
nicht besser.
Die Zahl 20 %
lässt Robin nicht mehr los.
Bei einer von fünf Personen
geht bei der Operation etwas schief
oder breitet sich die chronische Ent-
zündung danach an anderer Stelle aus.
Vier Wochen vor der OP begleite ich
Robin zu einer Endoskopie.
Im Universitätsspital Zürich
wird sein Dickdarm
ein letztes Mal untersucht.
* Maschinen piepsen. *
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen. Schön geträumt?
Ja, war nice.
Wie sieht es aus?
Sah es schlimm aus? Oder geht es?
Es ist wirklich nur
in den letzten 25, 30 cm entzündet.
Oben sieht es eigentlich gut aus,
aber unten ist es schwer entzündet.
Das ist ein Scheiss,
einen eigentlich gesunden Darm
zu amputieren.
Wenn es oben gut aussieht,
muss ja nicht der ganze raus.
Gibt es da keine Möglichkeit?
Wenn man bei Colitis ulcerosa
nur einen Teil rausnimmt,
kommt es ganz schlecht.
Würde man nur die Hälfte rausnehmen,
nur die linke Seite,
kommt danach die Entzündung häufig
im anderen Teil umso heftiger.
Was ich nicht verstehe: Die letzten
30 cm sind schwer entzündet.
Das verstehe ich, die sind
schon seit drei Jahren entzündet.
Das kriegt man wahrscheinlich
nicht in den Griff.
Aber der Dickdarm ...
... ist 2 m lang.
Und nur weil 30 cm entzündet sind,
wollen sie den ganzen Dickdarm
rausnehmen.
Also rein rational
begreife ich das noch nicht.
Ich empfinde das als Unsinn.
Also ... Das ist ... Ja ...
Robins Zweifel an der Operation
werden immer grösser.
Ein paar Tage später
im selben Spital.
Alle sechs Wochen kriegt er
eine Infusion: Immunsuppressiva.
Damit können Schübe
zwar hinausgezögert werden,
doch heftige Nebenwirkungen
sind die Folge.
Heute ist es vielleicht
das letzte Mal.
Daumen drücken.
Ich bin mir eben noch nicht sicher,
ob ich die Operation mache.
Aber alle Vorbereitungen
sind jetzt getroffen?
Ja, man müsste, sollte,
könnte es jetzt machen.
Ich habe mich eigentlich
dafür entschlossen,
aber ich kann mich nicht
dafür entschliessen.
Ich glaube,
wenn ich den Termin absage -
in 27 Tagen ist ja die OP -,
dann mache ich es nie.
Dann mache ich die Operation
wirklich nie,
sondern kämpfe weiter.
Kämpfe vielleicht noch Jahre
weiter so und bin Jahre geschwächt
und verpasse
ein energetisches Leben.
Verpasse ein Leben!
Wenn ich es mache
und es geht schief,
versaue ich mein Leben noch mehr.
Was ist das für ein Entscheid?
Ein Mensch
kann den gar nicht treffen.
Das ist unmöglich.
Ich kann den Entscheid
nicht treffen.
Wenn ich mich dazu entscheide,
mich nicht zu entscheiden,
passiert nichts und ich bleibe
einfach weiter in diesem State.
Ein lustiges Game:
Wie viel riskiert man dafür, dass es
einem vielleicht besser geht?
Aber ein Leben lang so weitermachen?
Darauf habe ich auch keine Lust.
Ein Leben lang so ...
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Der Entscheid wird dadurch erschwert,
dass sich Robin
ganz plötzlich besser fühlt -
psychisch, aber auch körperlich.
Ein Gespräch mit seinem Arzt
soll Klarheit schaffen.
Und wie sich herausstellt,
weist das Resultat der Endoskopie in
dieselbe Richtung wie Robins Gefühl.
Ganz ehrlich: So, wie es Ihnen
vor sechs bis acht Wochen ging,
als Sie am Boden waren,
hätte ich gesagt,
dass die Kolektomie
das Richtige sei.
Da hatten Sie keine Lust mehr.
Zweimal pro Woche
ging der Stuhl unkontrolliert weg
und Sie haben gesagt, so lohne
es sich nicht mehr, weiterzuleben.
Richtig.
Wenn ich Sie jetzt so sehe,
würde ich sagen,
kann man auf jeden Fall noch warten
und weiter versuchen,
das unter Kontrolle zu kriegen.
Die Entzündungswerte gehen runter.
Es bessert sich vom Labor her,
Sie sehen besser aus ...
Es kann wirklich gut sein,
dass diese Entscheidung
Druck weggenommen
und Stress reduziert hat.
Jetzt lassen Sie es laufen,
Sie lassen etwas los.
Wir wissen ja,
dass solche psychischen Komponenten
bei der Colitis viel dazu beitragen,
wie sich die Entzündung entwickelt.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass das
jetzt die Besserung mit sich bringt.
Kein Sport mehr,
nicht mehr auf die Ernährung gucken,
das gute Leben leben.
- Ein bisschen tiefenentspannt sein.
Das ist grundsätzlich
nicht schlecht.
Jetzt haben wir sogar
einen Entscheid:
Ich verschiebe, ja.
Erleichterung - aber nicht nur.
Also,
man muss sich das so vorstellen:
Man steht auf dem Fünfmeterbrett
und hat Angst zu springen -
die OP zu machen.
Man denkt:
"Es könnte so viel passieren."
"Ich könnte einen Bauchklatscher
machen."
"Es könnte mich hinhauen
und dann wird alles noch schlimmer."
Oder man springt einfach.
Ich gehe jetzt die Leiter
wieder runter und sage:
"Eigentlich
muss ich gar nicht springen."
Ich gehe wieder runter.
Und das fühlt sich
halt auch nicht gut an -
weil man nicht gesprungen ist.
Aber ich habe
die Risiken des Sprungs abgeschätzt.
Hätte ich einen Bauchklatscher
gemacht - puh!
Dann hätte ich abgekackt -
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Mein oberstes Ziel muss jetzt sein:
chillen.
Keinen Stress.
Alles easy nehmen,
essen, was ich will,
mir nicht so viele Gedanken
über meine Krankheit machen
und hoffen,
so in Remission zu kommen.
Seinen Vorsatz
kann er nicht lange halten.
Robin hat so viel Energie und Ideen,
wie schon lange nicht mehr.
Ich habe gute News:
Es geht mir nämlich deutlich besser
als vor vier Monaten.
Robin reisst wieder Projekte an,
trifft Freunde, ist als DJ unterwegs
und räumt für seine Radiosendung
sogar einen Award ab.
Meine Gesundheit ist kongruent
zu meinem Terminkalender:
Je besser es mir geht,
desto voller ist der Terminkalender,
und umgekehrt.
Das ist eigentlich dumm.
Aber:
Will man der tibetische Typ ...
... auf dem Berg sein,
der einfach meditiert und sagt,
er sei clean und easy mit allem?
Ist das erstrebenswert,
so ein Leben zu führen?
Ich sage Nein.
Ich sitze so euphorisch hier
und hoffe nicht ...
... dass ich in zwei Monaten
wieder ganz anders daliege und sage:
"Oh, so schlimm, so dumm!"
Schau, da sitzt er!
Roger.
Robin kostet die Momente aus,
in denen er sich gut fühlt.
Am Abend
steht ein Weihnachtsessen des Vereins
"Menschen mit Autoimmunerkrankung
und Handicap", MIAH,
in seinem Terminkalender.
Er wird überschwänglich empfangen.
In den letzten Jahren
ist er mit seinem Vlog
zu deren Sprachrohr geworden.
Am Treffen
wird über den Gesundheitszustand,
Therapien und Medikamente diskutiert.
Dieser Austausch mit der Community
ist ihm wichtig.
Ich treffe hier Leute,
denen es jetzt gerade schlecht geht.
Sie sehen,
wie gut es mir jetzt geht.
Sie sahen mich auch,
als es mir sehr schlecht ging.
Das macht auch Hoffnung.
Man sieht:
Kein Zustand ist für immer.
Es kann sich immer wieder verändern.
Ins Positive hoffentlich.
Leider auch ins Negative.
Aber ich glaube,
das gibt vielen Kraft, zu sehen:
"Es ging ihm so schlecht
und jetzt wieder gut."
"Das kann ich auch."
Und das ist so.
Kein Zustand ist für immer.
Dessen muss man sich bewusst sein.
Als hätte er es geahnt:
Zwei Wochen
nach diesem geselligen Abend
schlägt die Krankheit
Colitis ulcerosa
ganz plötzlich
und mit voller Wucht zurück.
Robin bricht unter dem erneuten Schub
zusammen.
Ich bin froh für jeden,
der die Krankheit im Griff hat.
Aus irgendeinem Grund
bringt es mein Körper nicht hin,
bringe ich es nicht hin.
Ich investiere jeden Tag ...
... so viele Stunden ...
... in meine verdammte Gesundheit.
Robin zieht sich zurück,
macht auch keine Videos mehr.
Zu gross sind die Schmerzen
und die Enttäuschung.
Er probiert
noch ein letztes Medikament aus,
doch auch das
zeigt nicht die gewünschte Wirkung.
So fällt ihm der Entscheid
diesmal leichter.
Jetzt geht's los.
Heute geht es ins Spital.
Was ich meinte,
verhindern zu können,
konnte ich nicht verhindern.
Der Dickdarm wird rausoperiert.
Ja, es ist Zeit.
Nach sieben Jahren mit dieser
Krankheit und allem Ausprobieren ...
... muss ich zum Schluss kommen,
dass es nicht geht.
Ja, ich muss ihn rausoperieren.
So ist das Leben
nicht mehr lebenswert.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall froh,
dass ich nicht mehr aufs WC muss,
denn das ist eine Qual.
Einen Tag vor der OP
beschäftigt ihn etwas sehr:
Es gibt Leute
in seiner Online-Community,
die ihm schreiben, er habe
zu wenig um seinen Darm gekämpft,
er würde aufgeben,
hätte dies und jenes
noch nicht ausprobiert.
Du bist verzweifelt
und in dieser Verzweiflung
kommen gesunde Menschen und sagen:
"Tu doch nicht so!
So schlimm kann es nicht sein."
"Du siehst doch gut aus.
Iss mal mehr Bananen!"
Das ist unglaublich und man
kann es den Leuten nicht erklären.
Es schreiben mir viele Jugendliche,
die sagen:
"Meine Eltern
nehmen meine Krankheit nicht ernst."
Der Arzt
versucht ihnen dann zu erklären,
was für eine Autoimmunerkrankung
er hat.
Und die Eltern nehmen es nicht wahr,
kapieren es nicht.
Sie denken, er könne nicht so lange
krank sein, solle nicht so tun.
Und der Witz ist:
Es kann jeden treffen.
Plötzlich, von heute auf morgen.
Du wächst auf ...
... mit einer Autoimmunerkrankung.
Das ganze Leben ist scheisse.
Schlimm!
Wie siehst du denn aus?
Wie aus dem Ei gepellt.
Mein Fahrer.
So muss ein Spitalfahrer aussehen.
Genau.
- Perfekt.
Weisst du, wieso der Bart?
- Damit du männlicher aussiehst?
Damit ich, wenn ich aus der Narkose
aufwache, sagen kann:
"Wo bin ich?"
"In Zürich im Unispital."
"Welches Jahr haben wir?"
"2019."
"2019!"
"Wer ist der Präsident von Amerika?"
"Trump!"
Deshalb. Für den Gag.
Robin verliert den Humor
auch dann nicht,
wenn ihm die Angst im Nacken sitzt.
Jetzt steht er auf dem Fünfmeterbrett
und muss springen.
Ich bin auch bei EXIT.
Wenn es schlimm wird,
kann ich immer noch sagen: "Fertig."
Aber es kommt ja gut.
Grundsätzlich. Zu 80 %.
- Du bist ja bei den Profis.
Ja, bei den Besten.
Der ist ja gar nicht so schwer.
Ist der leer?
- Nur Kleider drin.
Das Ziel ist,
dass ich im Juni wieder bereit bin,
also in zwei Monaten,
dass ich dann wieder arbeiten
und am Leben teilnehmen kann,
wieder in meine Energie komme.
Ja.
April 2019.
Ich besuche Robin
am Tag nach seiner Operation.
Der Hauptherd
seiner Autoimmunerkrankung,
der Dickdarm, wurde entfernt
und ein künstlicher Darmausgang,
ein sog. Stoma, angelegt.
Ich habe es überstanden ...
... und die Operation
hinter mich gebracht.
Aber ja, ich weiss, dass ich jetzt
einen langen Weg vor mir habe:
Reha.
Es wird sicher einen Monat gehen ...
... bis ich wieder stabil bin.
Aufsitzen.
Die Rehabilitation
ist einiges mühsamer
und dauert länger,
als von Robin erwartet.
Den steinigen Weg zur Besserung
hält er in seinem Videoblog fest.
Der zweite Tag nach der OP
ist ziemlich scheisse.
Ich habe starke Schmerzen im Bauch.
Tag 6 nach der OP.
Es geht mir
etwas besser als gestern,
aber noch nicht gut.
Ich pushe meinen Körper
ein bisschen.
Ich möchte gehen, gehen, gehen.
Am siebten, nein, achten Tag
nach der OP:
Jetzt wird es richtig gruselig:
Ich werde nämlich
mein Stoma wechseln.
Ich zittere immer noch, weil ich es
noch nicht verkraften kann.
Und jetzt
muss ich das hier andrücken.
Heute geht es mir schlechter
als gestern.
Ich bin mit 39,5 °C Fieber
aufgewacht.
Nach
einem dreiwöchigen Reha-Aufenthalt
kämpft Robin zu Hause
mit neuen Problemen:
Die starken Medikamente
zeigen Nebenwirkungen,
Opiate machen ihn abhängig
und depressive Verstimmungen
kommen hinzu.
So viel Müll!
Ich habe das Gefühl,
mein Körper sei ein Wrack.
Ich würde manchmal gerne
bodyswappen, switchen.
Jemandem sagen: "Komm, spring du mal
für eine Stunde in meinen Körper
und ich in deinen."
"Dann habe ich mal eine Stunde Pause
und du erlebst, was es bedeutet,
jeden Tag mit all den kleinen
Bullshit-Problemen zu kämpfen."
Doch mit den Wochen heilen die Wunden
und die Bullshit-Probleme
werden weniger.
Es ist Mitte September,
fünf Monate nach der Operation.
Die ersten zwei Monate waren hart.
Danach konnte ich fast drei Monate
lang den Sommer geniessen.
Ich habe eine neue Lebensqualität,
von der ich nie erwartet hätte,
sie nochmals zu kriegen.
Dank dieses Sacks!
Da hängt er.
Er bringt mir neue Lebensqualität,
die ich nicht erwartet hätte.
Ready? Gehst du vor?
- Ja.
Da unten ist es mega rutschig.
Bootfahren war immer mein Kraftort.
Es war schlimm,
als der nicht mehr so funktionierte.
Während einer Gummibootfahrt
auf der Limmat,
die bis nach Dietikon
rund anderthalb Stunden dauert,
musste ich kacken.
Dann kackte ich in die Limmat,
wie das Fische auch machen.
Es war schrecklich -
nicht nur für mich,
sondern auch für meine Freunde,
die dabei waren.
Keine guten Erinnerungen.
Ich bin so froh,
dass das jetzt wieder geht.
V.a. habe ich wieder Lust.
Ich bin ein ganz anderer Mensch.
Davor war es schon so, dass man
immer daran dachte - auch ich:
"Gehen wir wo hin,
wo er aufs Klo kann?"
"Es könnte sein,
dass er jetzt aufs Klo muss."
Dann hat er nur Sekunden.
Das hat einen eingeschränkt -
mich und auch Robin.
Er agiert jetzt wieder
auf eine ganz andere Art.
So gesehen
ist er schon ein anderer Mensch,
auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt, da auch alle Medikamente
draussen sind ...
Ich nehme gar nichts mehr.
Null. Nichts. Das war unvorstellbar.
Ich brauche kein Kortison,
keine Schmerzmittel, nichts.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich sei wieder ich,
denn das beeinflusst dich einfach.
Stösst du hinten ab?
Robin
träumt von noch mehr Lebensqualität -
von einem Leben ohne Stoma.
Darum entscheidet er sich
für einen J-Pouch,
der zwei weitere Operationen
notwendig macht.
Was passiert jetzt?
Sie nehmen das Stoma ab und es
gibt eine Verbindung zum Ausgang?
Die J-Pouch-Anlage
wird jetzt eingebaut.
Man nimmt nichts raus,
man tut etwas rein.- Ah, okay.
Einen künstlichen Dickdarm,
der aussieht wie ein J.
Ah, deswegen J-Pouch.
- Ja.
Und jetzt?
Logisch wird es gut.
Ich bin dann sicher fünf Monate weg.
* Ruhige Musik *
Am 3. Oktober
dann die zweite Operation von dreien.
Sehr nervös. Nicht im Kopf,
aber der Körper spinnt.
Ich glaube, der Körper weiss,
dass er jetzt drankommt.
Es wird alles umgelagert.
Heute Morgen ...
Aus einem Stück Dünndarm wird ein
künstliches Stuhlreservoir geformt,
das die Darmentleerung
hinauszögern soll.
Bei der dritten Operation
wird dieses Reservoir
wieder an den After angeschlossen.
* Maschinen piepsen. *
Dann gibt es die Möglichkeit,
dass ich später wieder
normal aussehe und aufs WC kann
und anscheinend
noch mehr Lebensqualität kriege.
Man redet ja immer
von Lebensqualität.
Wann hat das Leben genug Qualität?
Das sei eben so besser.
Ich will mich nicht mehr weiter
gegen die Operation sperren
und das jetzt einfach machen.
Auch wenn man das
nicht freiwillig machen würde.
Diese und auch die dritte Operation
im Dezember 2019 verlaufen gut.
Am Tag vor seinem 39. Geburtstag
kommt Robin Rehmann
aus einer Nachkontrolle.
Er hat sich verliebt und ist
mit seiner Freundin zusammengezogen.
Die Idee war wirklich,
in eine neue Wohnung zu ziehen.
Quasi durchstarten mit neuem Darm -
also ohne Dickdarm,
sagen wir es so -
und alles kommt gut,
aber so einfach
ist das leider auch nicht.
Die Idee,
dass man einfach gesund wird ...
... stimmt nicht, glaube ich.
Also ja, das hat mir
auch niemand so verkauft,
dass ich den Dickdarm
rausnehmen kann
und dann wie ein junges Reh
übers Feld hüpfe.
Aber ich hätte es mir gerne
so vorgestellt.
Online verkündet er in dieser Zeit
überraschend
das Ende
seines Colitis-ulcerosa-Vlogs -
nach 250 Videos.
Ich bin ehrlich:
Es lief bei mir nicht nach Plan.
Ich habe eine komische Wunde
am Bauch.
Auch eine Autoimmun-Scheisse.
Ich kann es dir nachher zeigen.
Der Darm ist zu eng
und funktioniert nicht richtig.
Nur Theater.
Ich könnte schon noch Videos machen
und in die Kamera jammern:
"Alles ist schlecht
und es funktioniert nicht."
Aber was hilft das?
Ausser mich selbst zu bemitleiden?
Ich möchte die Leute ja motivieren,
an ihrer Situation etwas zu ändern.
Es ist scheisse, aber
es ist nicht das Ende des Lebens,
definitiv nicht.
Es ist eine neue Herausforderung.
Die einen machen Extremsport
oder so,
ich mache einfach meine Krankheit.
Irgendwann
habe ich das Loch nicht mehr,
aber dann
habe ich irgendein anderes Problem.
Ich glaube, wenn man das
dann so sieht, merkt man erst,
wie geil
ein funktionierender Körper ist.
Jeder meint, kacken zu können
und kein Loch im Bauch zu haben,
sei völlig normal.
Und hat man einen Spiess im Finger,
denkt man: "Geht's noch?"
Dabei
ist es nicht selbstverständlich,
dass alles gut funktioniert.
Darum denke ich:
Wenn man so eine Krankheit hat
wie ich,
schätzt man die Gesundheit
viel, viel mehr.
Wenn es normal ist,
wenn einfach alles gut ist,
ist man zufrieden und glücklich.
Ich erinnere mich noch daran,
als ich noch "gesund" war ...
... und es mir körperlich gut ging:
Das reichte nicht.
Mein Körper
suchte dann etwas anderes.
Im Kopf
fühlte ich mich einfach nicht wohl.
Jetzt reicht es, gesund zu sein,
habe ich das Gefühl.
Es ist wie genug.
Ich brauche gar nicht mehr.
Dann bin ich glücklich.
So ein Glücksgefühl
habe ich vorher nie erreicht.
Ich glaube, es braucht den Schmerz,
und direkt dahinter ist das Glück.
Wenn man diesen Schmerz nicht hatte,
ist das Glück gar nicht so stark da.
Ein halbes Jahr später,
im August 2020.
Willkommen bei SRF Virus bei
"Rehmann S.O.S. - Sick of Silence"!
Das ist die Sendung,
in der wir über Dinge sprechen,
über die viele sich nicht trauen
zu reden: eigene Emotionen.
Robin moderiert wieder.
Es geht ihm gut.
Trotzdem: ein normales Leben,
wie vor dem Ausbruch der Krankheit,
wird er nie mehr haben.
Es ist halt schon so:
Ohne Dickdarm hat man nicht mehr
die Energie, die man vorher hatte.
Ich merke das auch.
Ich habe noch keine Wanderung
oder längeren Spaziergang gemacht.
Ich muss schon immer sitzen,
Pause machen
und darauf achten,
meine Energie zu bündeln.
Auch hat er immer noch
sechs bis acht Stuhlgänge pro Tag.
Nachts muss er deswegen aufstehen.
Die Autoimmunerkrankung
Colitis ulcerosa ist unheilbar.
Sie kann sich jedoch
durch die Entfernung des Dickdarms
nicht mehr in ihrer Vehemenz zeigen.
Ich bereue die Operation
auf keinen Fall.
Ich bin froh,
dass ich es gemacht habe.
Symptomatisch ist es sicher besser.
Aber ...
... es war
eine richtig heftige Geschichte.
Ich würde es spontan
nicht noch einmal machen.
Der Leidensdruck
muss wirklich hoch sein,
damit man sich darauf einlässt.
Es ist auch schwierig zu sagen,
dass unser Beitrag jetzt fertig ist,
denn das Leben geht immer weiter.
Bei mir machte die Krankheit
einen grossen Teil davon aus.
Die wird immer mitschwingen.
Aber ich hoffe,
dass sie in den nächsten Jahren
nicht mehr die Hauptrolle hat
wie in den letzten zwei Jahren.
Ich glaube, so eine Krankheit kann
man sich nicht wirklich vorstellen.
Aber wenn sie mal da ist ...
... kommt man damit
irgendwie zurecht.
Es gibt ja viele,
die so über ihre Kinder sprechen.
Die Diagnose chronisch krank
bedeutet für immer.
Aber bei Robin
steht die Krankheit heute nicht mehr
im Mittelpunkt seines Lebens.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021